The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NEHA NARULA: OK,
let's get started.
I hope everybody had
a great long weekend.
So I'm teaching
today, and today we're
going to be talking
about transactions.
So just to recap where
we've been so far,
Tadge just sort of explained
signatures in Bitcoin,
in particular RSA and ECDSA,
and told us a little bit
about Merkle trees.
And so these are some of
the underlying primitives
that we need to
know about in order
to understand how most
of the blockchains today
are constructed.
So we've spent a bit of time
talking about the underlying
primitives, now let's start to
put them together a little bit
to understand what
goes into a blockchain.
So if you recall,
this is a slide
that Tadge has shown before.
And I'm really sorry about this
quadrant, but I don't know,
I don't think I can
control this individually.
So we'll definitely post
the slides of course,
but let me know if something
is really confusing.
Just raise your hand.
So this is something that
you guys have seen before,
and it's like a very sort
of rough approximation
of a hash chain.
So what we have
here is we have--
this doesn't actually
show the previous,
but what we have here
is we have some message,
we have a nonce, such that
when you hash these three
things together, you
get this hash value,
which has a certain number of
leading zeros at the beginning.
In this case, it's
two leading zeros.
And when we construct
the next block,
we implicitly point
to this previous block
by including that hash inside of
this when we produce this hash.
So note that there
isn't actually
a physical pointer
or a memory address
pointer type thing connecting
these two things together.
And note that this
block does not actually
contain the hash of itself.
But we are sort of
implicitly pointing to this
by including the hash of this
block in the following block.
And so on over here-- again,
this is a different message,
a different nonce,
and it includes
the hash of this block
instead of the one before.
And by including the
hash of this block,
it's also implicitly including
the hash of this block,
because that's right here.
And so what we're going to see
is that if you change anything
about the previous blocks in
the blockchain-- for example,
if you change this message--
then you're going to need
to change the nonce in order
to get the hash
to compute right.
That's going to be
a different hash.
And that change is
going to trickle down
through the entire blockchain.
And so that's what
makes these things what
we call tamper-proof, the fact
that there are these hashes,
these hashes are
collision-resistant.
And so it's very difficult. You
can't change what's in the past
without having it
reflected in the future.
So now let's go into
a little bit more
detail about exactly what
this message thing is.
We've talked about the
previous hash pointers,
we've talked about
the nonce, we've
talked about proof of work.
But what actually goes
inside of a block?
Well, we have this
general-- we've
kind of been alluding
to it, but what
goes inside a block
are transactions.
We're trying to build
a payment system here.
So what do we need to
have in a transaction?
What should a
transaction look like?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Inputs and outputs.
NEHA NARULA: OK,
inputs and outputs.
Maybe even like a higher
level here, semantically,
what do we want
in a transaction?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: A sender, a receiver,
an amount, like a message.
NEHA NARULA: OK, a sender,
a receiver, an amount.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Transaction ID.
NEHA NARULA: OK, an ID,
some way of referencing it.
Anybody else.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: A proof that
it's a legit transaction.
NEHA NARULA: A proof that it's
a legit transaction, right,
exactly.
So what we need is those
things that you guys just said.
We need to know the amount,
how much of this coin
we're transferring, we need to
know where it's coming from,
and in particular we need an
authorization of some sort
that that user actually
authorized the spend,
and we need who we're paying.
And so unfortunately
this is in the dark part,
but this is sort of a little
rough sketch of a transaction.
And we have Alice who's
spending $5.00 to Bob,
and we have this
authorization here.
And this authorization, given we
just learned about signatures,
signatures are a great
way to do authorization
because it's something that
only Alice can produce.
So I don't know if
you can see this,
but there are
question marks here.
So what should Alice
sign to show that she
authorized this transaction?
What do you think
would be a good thing--
what is a good message
for her to sign
for her to indicate her
authority, her desire
to produce this transaction
and spend her funds?
AUDIENCE: Private key.
NEHA NARULA: Her private key?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NEHA NARULA: She should
sign her private key?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the whole transaction.
NEHA NARULA: The
whole transaction, OK.
So let's talk about
signing the private key.
Let's say that she did
sign her private key.
The problem with a
signature is that, in order
to tell if the
signature is valid,
you need the thing
that you signed.
So she would have to include her
private key, which would then
share her private key with
everyone, which isn't really
a good way for her to use
her public and private key.
She could certainly
sign the transaction.
And the nice thing about
signing the transaction--
this is all blue, indicating
that she's signing it--
is that she's signing all
three of these things as well.
She's saying, I want to pay
Bob, I want to pay Bob $5.
Now what's the problem with
signing the transaction?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you just
keep using it if you were Bob?
NEHA NARULA: So that is an
excellent point-- you could
keep using it if you were Bob.
And we'll get into that
a little bit later.
But another problem
here is, the way
that I've shown it right now,
she's signing the signature.
The signature is kind of
part of the transaction.
And so you want to make
sure that you're not--
when you sign a
transaction, you're
signing everything but
the signature, right,
because you can't
produce the signature.
You can't sign the
signature without knowing
what the signature is.
It would be like a whole
new type of proof of work
on the transaction.
So I don't know if
you can see this,
but this says transaction
minus signature.
And in fact, we can even
make that a little bit easier
by turning that into a
hash of the transaction,
not including the signature.
Because that sort of
brings the message
down to a smaller thing.
And from what we know about
hash functions you can't really,
given a message and a
hash of that message,
it's difficult to produce
another message that
would hash to the same thing.
So this hash serves as
kind of an identifier
for the transaction as a whole.
In fact, Bitcoin uses the hash
of this as the transaction ID.
So this is how we
refer to transactions.
And it's a nice
small thing to sign,
which indicates Alice's
intent to spend her funds.
So one thing that I kind of
want to go into a little bit
is that there's a couple
different ways for thinking
about transactions, and
what transactions actually
look like, and how
they're stored,
and how we sort
of specify coins.
And the most natural model, to
me, anyway, not to everybody,
perhaps, is what I call
the account-based model.
So it's kind of like what
we were doing before,
when we saw the
banks, and we were
talking about
banks keeping track
of how much funds people have.
And this is sort of how you and
I might think of our own bank
accounts.
I think in my bank account
as having a certain amount
of funds in it.
And so in the
account-based model,
users have certain amounts
or balances associated
with their usernames.
And when a transaction comes in,
like Alice wants to give $5.00
to Bob, then what might
happen is that the nodes
in the network which are all
maintaining, in a unified way,
this balance sheet,
will end up saying, OK,
Alice had 10 and Bob had zero.
Alice wants to
give $5.00 to Bob.
Let's subtract $5.00 from
Alice's account and give it
to Bob.
And so what the
nodes would do here
to see if this transaction
was valid would be
they would check the
signature to make sure
that Alice actually
authorized this transaction,
and they would also
make sure that Alice
had the funds to spend.
And in the account-based
model, the way
that you check to see
if Alice has the funds
to spend as you literally
look at her balance,
and you look at the
amount she wants to spend,
and you make sure that if
she spends that amount,
the balance won't go below zero.
So this is actually the
model that Ethereum uses.
It's not the model
that Bitcoin uses.
So just sort of
to summarize, you
store a list of
accounts and balances,
a transaction is valid if there
is a balance in the account,
and then when a
transaction is processed,
you debit the sender and
credit the receiver-- so
very straightforward.
So like I said, this is
a way Ethereum works,
and it's a little
bit more natural,
I think, to think about.
But this is not the way
Bitcoin works, actually.
Bitcoin has a very
different model
of coins and of transactions.
And I think-- when I was
learning about how Bitcoin
worked and how
Ethereum worked, I
found Bitcoin's model
a little bit unnatural
until I went through
this exercise of thinking
about something
called replay attacks.
And this is what [? Issan ?]
mentioned earlier, which
is when you have
this transaction,
and you send it to the
network, and the network
processes the transaction
and debits Alice and credits
Bob, what is to prevent a
malicious agent from noticing
that transaction and
rebroadcasting it again
to the network, so basically
repeatedly debiting
Alice until she doesn't
have any funds left.
So can you guys think of a
way to maybe get around this?
What would you do?
How would you prevent
this replay attack?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: She can add a specific
ID to the time, for instance,
[INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: So one thing
is adding a time, sure.
Time is a little bit tricky
because of the nature
of the system.
But a time is a
pretty good idea.
A unique number of
some kind certainly
would help, because that
way if you saw a transaction
with the same number,
then you'd know,
OK, this transaction
has been seen before.
This is a repeat.
This is a rebroadcast.
This is not something
I should process.
So Ethereum actually
does something like this.
There is this number included
in every transaction.
But the tricky part about the
way that Ethereum does this--
and we're going to learn
more about Ethereum later
on in the course, we're going
to have a guest lecturer come
in and teach us about that--
is that it requires you to keep
track of all of the numbers
you've seen.
And you have to
do this per user.
And so all the
nodes in the network
have to keep track
of all of the nonces
that they've seen per user.
And so if a user uses Ethereum
once and then goes away,
all of the nodes have to
keep that state forever,
essentially, just
in case someone
comes back and rebroadcasts
another transaction.
So Bitcoin, like I said, and
I keep saying, does something.
And there's nothing
wrong with this model.
We'll sort of
compare and contrast.
Like I said, it's
what Ethereum uses.
But I think that this is part
of the motivation for why
Bitcoin was designed
the way that it was.
And so Bitcoin uses this idea
called unspent transaction
outputs.
So you'll notice, over
here, we don't have
any notion of a coin, per se.
There are just
amounts, and amounts
are debited and credited.
And if Alice spends to Bob,
and Alice spends to Carol,
and they come in
different orders,
either one could happen first.
There's no notion of, like,
Carol gets these coins
and Bob gets these coins.
But Bitcoin is a
little bit different.
All coins are not the same.
And when you're
spending, you don't just
include an amount you refer
back to the specific coin
that you are spending.
So you actually have to refer
to a coin in order to spend it.
And this is the
really weird part--
coins are created,
destroyed, consumed,
and then new coins are
created every transaction.
So whenever you
spend your bitcoin,
you have to spend
it in its entirety.
That bitcoin is then destroyed,
and new coins are created.
And there's a rule, in the
entire system, that a coin can
only be spent once.
So we'll go into
exactly what that
looks like in a
transaction, but I
want to know if there are
any questions about that
first, about that idea.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Aren't coins fungible?
So what if you spend maybe
a little bit of a coin
on some candy or something?
NEHA NARULA: That's
a great question.
So the question is,
aren't coins fungible?
So first of all, coins
aren't fungible, actually.
They are very specific.
You can see a coin.
But the question
about what happens
if you only want to spend part
of a coin is a great question.
And we'll see how you
do that in the way
that the transaction
is constructed.
But the short answer is, if you
want to spend part of a coin,
you have to spend
the whole coin,
spend the part that you
want to someone else,
and then spend the rest
of it back to yourself,
creating a new coin
in the process.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Coins are consumed,
and for the new ones,
who will own the new ones?
NEHA NARULA: Whoever you say
should own the new ones when--
a transaction consumes coins
and creates new ones as payment.
And as the creator of that
transaction, as the spender,
I will decide who should
get the new coins.
And I'll show you the
details of this in a moment.
AUDIENCE: You're
saying coins, but do
you actually mean the full
balance in the account, right?
NEHA NARULA: No, not exactly
full balance in the account.
So let's go a little
bit further to look
at what's happening here.
Because Bitcoin doesn't
actually keep track of balances.
So let's take a look at
what a transaction actually
looks like.
So a transaction has
many different parts,
but we're going to focus
on two parts, which
is the inputs and outputs.
And here I'm showing
a transaction
with one input and one output.
Now, an input
actually refers back
to another transaction's output.
So let's assume-- and we'll get
into how this is done later--
but let's assume that there
are coins in the system.
Let's just assume that some
coins have been created out
of nowhere.
Let's say, in particular,
that maybe 12.5 coins have
been created out of nowhere.
And so there's a
transaction that
outputs 12.5 coins to Alice.
And Alice wants to
spend those coins.
And so Alice would
create a new transaction
that points back to
the transaction where
she received those coins.
And the way that she
points back to that
is using the transaction ID of
the previous transaction, which
you remember is just
the hash, the index,
meaning which output of the
previous transaction she's
intending to spend,
and something
called a scriptSig, which
is her authorization
to spend that output.
So this is how Alice
refers back to the output
she wants to spend.
And when I say coin, I'm
referring to outputs.
So outputs can be for
different amounts.
You could create an output--
you could spend 12.5 coins and
create many different outputs
of many different amounts, and
send them to different people.
if you wanted to.
So this is a format
of a transaction.
There is an input
which points back
to a previous
transaction's output
that you're intending to spend.
And then the way
that you spend it--
you're consuming that
output, essentially,
by pointing back to
it with this input--
the way that you spend it
by producing a new output.
And again, this
transaction isn't just
one input and one output,
it could have many.
And the output that you
produce has something
called a scriptPubKey.
What the scriptPubKey
is, the scriptPubKey
is a way of specifying
the conditions under which
this output can be redeemed.
So in its simplest sense, you
might have the scriptSig merely
be a signature, just
Alice's signature, saying,
I have the right to spend this.
And if Alice is spending to
Bob, then maybe the scriptPubKey
would actually just
be Bob's public key.
And the implied
meaning there would
be, anyone who could
produce the signature
of the corresponding private
key with that public key
could then spend this output.
One thing is that these
two things together--
the previous transaction
ID and the index--
serves to uniquely
identify an output.
So these two things uniquely
identify some money to spend.
And the value that's
specified in the output
is actually specified in
something called Satoshis,
and there are 10 to the eighth
Satoshis in one bitcoin.
So the value doesn't have
any decimal places in it.
It is always an integer.
And output is what I'm referring
to when I say the word, coin.
So, questions on this
sort of general setup.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about index [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Sure.
OK, the index is--
remember how I said there
could be multiple outputs?
The index simply
refers to which output
in the previous transaction
you're talking about.
Was there a question back there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm a little
bit confused about the--
So you have one input that
can generate several outputs?
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
provide an example?
NEHA NARULA: Sure, yes.
We'll get to that in
a moment, actually.
But maybe I could just
draw one on the board.
So you could certainly
have a transaction
that has multiple outputs.
And so this input
here would refer back
to some previous
transaction's outputs.
And let's say that this was,
for example, 20 bitcoin.
Then this needs to
consume 20 bitcoin.
And it can spread that
20 bitcoin out in any way
that it wants.
And there are some
details here that we're
going to get to in a moment.
But basically, you
have that 20 here.
You could send five
here, 10 here, five here.
And each of these outputs would
have its own scriptPubKey,
its own rules for
how to redeem it.
And each output
has its own amount.
Yep.
TADGE DRYJA: It's also
possible with multiple inputs
[INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So where does
the name, chain, come from?
Is it more like a
tree, or is it--
NEHA NARULA: That's
a good question.
So if you go back to the slide
where I sort of was showing--
this is where the name,
chain, comes from, here.
[CHUCKLING]
So what we're talking
about right now
is what goes inside each block.
And what goes inside each
block are transactions.
So for the moment, you can
pretend like each block only
has one transaction
in it, but a block
can contain a set
of transactions.
But the chain part comes
from how we actually
chain these blocks of
transactions together.
So let's talk about scriptSigs
and scriptPubKeys a little bit
more.
So scriptPubKeys, like I
said, are in the outputs.
And you can think of
them as predicates.
So scriptPubKeys
specify a predicate
on how someone can
redeem this output.
OK, so remember a transaction
can have multiple inputs,
multiple outputs.
Each output has its
own scriptPubKey.
scriptSigs, which
are in the inputs,
helps satisfy the
predicate that's
specified in the scriptPubKey.
So we would have a
scriptPubKey here, And.
We would have a scriptSig here.
And this scriptSig, if this
is a valid transaction,
would explain how to
satisfy the scriptPubKey.
So the scriptPubKey would set
up a predicate on the output.
The most common
predicate is, produce
a signature and a public key
that satisfies this hash.
And the scriptSig would
provide the information
necessary to satisfy
that predicate.
So what does it mean to
have money in this system?
What does it mean to
be able to spend money?
What does it mean
for Alice to be
able to transfer money to Bob?
It means Alice knows
some information that
allows her to produce
a satisfying scriptSig
for some outputs out there.
That's what having money means.
It's not an account balance.
So questions on that?
Because it's a
little non-intuitive.
But the important
thing to note here
is the nodes in
the Bitcoin network
are not keeping track of
how much money you have.
It's your job to keep track
of how much money you have,
or a wallet's job.
And we'll talk more
about wallets later.
And the way that you
do that is by knowing
how many outputs there are out
there that you can actually
redeem--
that you have the
knowledge to redeem.
Like I said, a transaction
can have multiple inputs
and multiple outputs.
And each input comes
with its own scriptSig,
and each output comes
with its own scriptPubKey.
So it's not that there's one
scriptSig and one scriptPubKey
for the entire transaction.
The transaction
can actually spend
multiple different
outputs and produce
multiple different new outputs.
And these outputs could have
nothing to do with each other.
Here, this input might
point to a previous output
that Alice knows how to spend.
And this input might
point to a previous output
the Carol knows how to spend.
And you can actually
combine both of those
into the same
transaction, assuming
you can produce a transaction
with the right scriptSigs.
Now, Alice and Carol might
have to talk to each other
in order to produce
this transaction,
because it's going to
need both signatures,
but they could do it.
AUDIENCE: What prevents
people from sort
of shuffling around and
changing the outputs
and inputs [INAUDIBLE]?
NEHA NARULA: Ah, great question.
So what prevents
people from shuffling
around inputs and the outputs?
Well, part of it
is because this is
serialized into a transaction.
And that transaction is hashed,
and then these signatures
are on that transaction hash.
Remember, we saw that
from a few slides before.
So if you were to
flip around the order
or if you were to trying
to change any bits in here
and change the pubkey,
you would end up
changing the hash
of the transaction
and this signature would
no longer be valid.
And something also that's
important to note--
only valid transactions get
accepted to the blockchain.
So all of the nodes are
checking to make sure
that these scriptPubKeys and
these scriptSigs work out.
And I'll show you the
rules that they're
checking in just a moment.
And so if anything
doesn't match,
if this signature is not a valid
scriptSig for whatever output
it's pointing to, this is
an invalid transaction,
no one will accept it.
In fact, most nodes won't
even pass it around,
and it will not get
into the blockchain.
Or if it does get
into the blockchain,
all of the nodes who
are following the rules
of the network will ignore it.
Because if a
transaction is invalid,
it means the entire
block is invalid,
and it means any chain building
off that block is also invalid.
So nodes that are following
the rules of the network, which
are, these should be valid,
will not listen to that,
and will completely
ignore that entire chain.
So here's another visual of
what it looks like to have--
and this is not with the
blockchain looks like.
I want to be clear.
The blockchain just
a set of blocks
pointing to previous blocks.
What we have here
is more sort of
like the logical
representation of what
a transaction looks like.
So you have a
transaction right here,
and you have two inputs
in this transaction.
And the first one is
pointing to the second output
of this previous transaction
that happened over here.
So this transaction has a hash.
And maybe this is the hash
of the entire transaction.
And so in order to spend
that output over there,
you specify the hash,
you specify the index--
so 012, you specify
this index right here--
and you provide a
scriptSig that will
validate according to
whatever the scriptPubKey is
for that output.
So note here, this
transaction doesn't care
what those outputs are at all.
It's not using those.
It's not looking at those.
Someone else might spend
those, someone else
might not spend those.
It's just spending
this one right here.
And in the act of spending
this one right here,
it doesn't make those other ones
invalid in the simplest form.
Those could still be
spent by someone else.
So outputs are
consumed separately.
So here, it's pointing to
a different transaction,
a transaction with this hash.
And so it specifies
the transaction ID,
and then it specifies which
output in that transaction
it's spending.
In this case, it's the third
one, so it has index 2.
And it provides a
satisfying scriptSig
for this output,
which probably is
totally different
than the satisfying
scriptSig for that output.
So this is what this transaction
has to specify in order
to spend those outputs.
And it can produce whatever
new outputs it wants
to produce under certain rules.
AUDIENCE: So in that example,
that whole box actually
points to something else?
That's not these two
boxes on the left, right?
NEHA NARULA: This box?
What do you mean when
you say, points to?
AUDIENCE: [? Their ?]
blockchain sequence.
NEHA NARULA: Yeah.
This is something
that will be inside
of the blockchain-- inside
of a block in the blockchain.
So this doesn't actually
point to anything.
It contains hashes.
Literally, it just
contains these bytes,
these hashes of the
transactions that it's spending.
And those are kind of
like a pointer in a sense.
But when it comes to
the entire blockchain,
this is one part of one block.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yeah, I know.
Can you guys see this at all?
Can you still see that or no?
OK, good.
OK, great.
You had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so in one
of the earlier slides,
you showed [INAUDIBLE] Is
that signature the same
as scriptSig, or--
NEHA NARULA: No,
that was sort of more
like an idealized transaction.
So this is what a transaction
actually looks like,
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: But the
scriptSig is still
inside the transaction itself.
NEHA NARULA: The scriptSig
is inside the transaction.
But when you sign
the transaction,
you don't sign the scriptSigs
because the scriptSigs include
the signature of
the transaction.
And it's important to
note, the scriptSig
includes the signature of
the transaction as a whole,
not just this part of it.
TADGE DRYJA: This actually
[INAUDIBLE] We're not talking
about it now, but
that was sort of--
there's bugs involved
at that point.
NEHA NARULA: Yeah,
we're not going
to talk about [INAUDIBLE].
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what prevents
two different transactions
pointing back at the
same [INAUDIBLE]??
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
So OK, I said that there's this
rule that outputs are supposed
to only be consumed once.
But I can definitely produce
another transaction which
points back to that output.
I could send it to the network.
And what would happen is
the nodes in the network,
assuming they're
following consensus rules,
would note that this
had already been spent.
So if this is already--
if they've already
seen a valid transaction
that consumes an output,
they will not accept
another transaction that
tries to spend the same output.
That's what's known
as a double-spend.
And so all the
nodes in the network
together are
maintaining this rule.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it going to
be kind of hard to traverse
backwards and figure
out [INAUDIBLE]
pointing [INAUDIBLE]?
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
Yes, this seems kind
of annoying, right?
You see this transaction,
and OK, there's
some random bytes in
here, and a signature,
and how am I supposed to
figure out what this goes to?
How am I supposed to
figure out whether this
is a valid transaction,
whether it's been spent or not?
And the answer is
that every single node
is maintaining a lot
of data structures
in order to make this faster.
And in fact they're
maintaining a data structure
called the UTXO set.
And I'll tell you a little bit
about the UTXO set in a minute.
And I'll tell you how
it's created in a moment.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
transaction fees
and how these transactions pass
in to the blockchain itself?
NEHA NARULA: Sure.
So I'm not going to
go into how a block--
what a block is composed of.
I'm not going to go into
what a block is composed of,
but we will tomorrow.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just to confirm,
with the [INAUDIBLE] scriptSig,
it's not usually
[? taking ?] this,
it's [INAUDIBLE]
the transaction.
NEHA NARULA: I'm
sorry, could you say--
AUDIENCE: ScriptSig, [INAUDIBLE]
or is it unique for each index?
NEHA NARULA: Yes, there
is a different scriptSig
for each input.
There's a different
scriptSig for each input,
but that scriptSig signs
most of the transaction.
So the scriptSig,
there's a different one,
because different outputs
could have different satisfying
conditions.
But the scriptSig has
to sign a message,
or it has to produce something.
Actually, we're going to go
into a few specific scriptSigs,
and I think it'll be a lot
clearer exactly what this is.
Because it's not clear right
now what goes in the scriptSig
or in the scriptPubKey.
So this is sort of like a
logical representation of what
a transaction looks like.
It refers to the
previous transaction
that it's spending from.
And the important
things to note here
are you don't have to
spend all of the outputs
in a transaction, you
can just spend one.
But you must consume
that output entirely
when you produce
your new outputs.
And so this is what's actually--
this is the JSON representation
of a transaction in Bitcoin.
And so this is probably
pretty hard to read,
and I don't think it's
worth it to try to look
at everything in great detail.
But when we have the slides up,
you can take a look at this.
And this is literally what
goes inside a transaction.
And there are few fields that
I'm not talking about here.
One is the version, and
another is the lock time.
And I think when we talk--
these scripts, these
scriptPubKey and scriptSig
can actually get quite
interesting and quite complex.
That's what makes
Bitcoin so cool.
And I think when we get into
that discussion about all
the different things
that can go into that,
then we'll talk a little bit
more about what lock time is.
But the short answer is,
a lock time tells you
at what point in time
this transaction is valid.
So until that lock time
happens, the transaction
is not valid and can't be
included in the blockchain.
So this transaction has
a lock time of zero,
meaning it's valid
immediately and can
be included in the blockchain.
So here, this has one input.
The input has the
transaction ID and the index.
So that's zero, so it's spending
the first output of whatever
that transaction is.
And it has some
scriptSig, which is empty.
And then this is the
output that it's producing.
It's spending 49.99 bitcoins
from that previous output.
And it's spending
it to a new output.
And these are the rules for
redeeming this new output.
Let's talk about
consensus rules.
So I keep using
the word, valid--
this transaction is valid,
this transaction is invalid.
And so there are
these implicit rules
to Bitcoin, which are defined
by the software, which
state what makes a valid
transaction or a valid block.
For transactions specifically,
the sum of the inputs
has to be less than or equal
to the sum of the outputs.
So you can't create
money out of nowhere.
You can't spend more than you're
putting into a transaction.
And why less than or equal to?
Fees, exactly.
So the difference in the outputs
and the inputs is implicit.
And it's a fee that
essentially just goes
to the miner, the person
who purchases the block.
There is one exception
to this rule.
It's a transaction called
the coinbase transaction--
no relation to the company.
It's not named
after the company.
I think the company
is named after it.
But it's the first
transaction in a block.
And it's the transaction that
gives out the block reward.
So the first transaction
in a block is special.
It doesn't have any inputs.
Or it does have inputs,
but they're meaningless.
And it produces
the block reward.
So right now, the block
reward is 12.5 bitcoins.
So every time a
block is produced,
every time someone solves
that proof-of-work puzzle
and produces a block,
they include a transaction
at the very beginning that
usually gives themselves
12.5 bitcoin plus
whatever fees are
implicit as the sum of all of
the transactions in the block.
So this invariant
must be maintained,
except for the coinbase
transaction, of which there
is one in every block.
And then this
invariant must also
be maintained, which--
oh, yes, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Who
determines the fees?
NEHA NARULA: The people
creating the transaction
determine the fees.
So when I create
a transaction, I'm
specifying which outputs I'm
spending, and putting them
in my inputs, and I'm
producing the outputs.
So I just have to
maintain that invariant.
So let's say that I'm spending
an input worth five bitcoin.
I could produce an output
worth five bitcoin,
meaning that the fee is zero.
It's very unlikely
that my transaction
would get accepted into the
blockchain with a fee of zero.
It's possible, sure.
But if I'm not mining
myself, why would
a miner take my
transaction when they
could take a transaction that
has a higher fee associated
with it?
And the fee is implicit.
It's the difference between
the sum of the inputs
and the sum of the outputs.
AUDIENCE: So higher the
fees, it's more likely
that you will be processed--
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
Any other questions
at this point?
AUDIENCE: Are these
taken out of the inputs
or out of the outputs?
NEHA NARULA: The
fee is implicit.
So, in the inputs,
you're consuming--
so let's use this
example right here.
So here, we're
consuming this output,
which has 20 bitcoin in it.
So implicitly, this thing
has 20 bitcoin to spend.
Now, before, I had
it set up as 5-10-5.
And so 20 needs
to be greater than
or equal to 5 plus 10 plus 5.
And it is, great, 20 is
greater than or equal to 20.
What I could do is I could
change this number to a four.
And so what this means is--
notice that this
adds up to 19 now.
Where did that one bitcoin go?
That one bitcoin
implicitly goes to whoever
produces the block in which
that contains this transaction.
AUDIENCE: So is
that greater than--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: No, but [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: No.
AUDIENCE: On the slide.
NEHA NARULA: Yeah, you're right.
Sorry, that should be
greater than or equal to.
Sorry about that.
So another invariant that
needs to be maintained
is that this output
has not already
been referenced in
another transaction,
in another valid transaction.
And then, as I alluded
to, a final invariant
is around the lock time.
So let's go into an example
of how this actually works,
this scriptSig and
scriptPubKey thing.
So I haven't really gone into
detail yet about what this is.
I sort of implied that this
specified a key and this
specified a signature.
But what does this
actually look like?
And I mean, I think this is
really, really interesting,
actually.
Because Bitcoin lets
you specify lots
of different scriptPubKeys and
lots of different scriptSigs.
And so this gives you
this kind of flexibility
so that you can program in
different kinds of conditions
on what it takes to
redeem a transaction.
So we're just going to talk
about a couple very simple
ones.
Because to get into
more complex stuff,
we need to go really deep
into this word, script.
So basically the scriptPubKey
and the scriptSig
are composed of opcodes.
So Bitcoin has a little
less than 200 opcodes,
and you write Bitcoin
scripts using these opcodes.
So let's talk about the
most common Bitcoin script,
which is Pay to Pubkey Hash.
So the idea here is you want
to send money to a public key.
So Alice has Bob's public key,
and Alice wants to pay Bob.
And so Alice wants to send
money to Bob's public key.
Well, the reason
that this is called
pubkey hash, public
keys are kind of big,
and there's this nice--
you can kind of make
this nice observation
that you don't necessarily
have to put the whole
public key in the output.
You can put a hash of
the public in the output.
And I think Tadge already talked
about this when he was talking
about Bitcoin addresses.
So the scriptPubKey
is instructions
on how to verify a signature
of a public key that
has been hashed
and the scriptSig
is that signature and
the actual public key,
the pre-image of
the hash public key.
And this is what
that looks like.
So this is literally
the scriptPubKey
for a Pay to Pubkey
Hash input or output,
and this is literally the
scriptSig that would you would
use to redeem that output.
So this right here would
go inside one of these.
And it would set the
conditions under which
you could redeem this output.
And this right here
would go inside the input
of the transaction
that's redeeming it.
And let's take a look at
how this actually works.
So what the Bitcoin Script
Interpreter does is,
when it's evaluating whether
or not a transaction is valid,
it takes a look at
the input, and it
looks at which previous
transaction it's looking at
and which index the output is,
and it grabs the scriptPubKey.
Well, first of all, it makes
sure that output hasn't already
been spent.
Then it grabs the scriptPubKey,
and it takes the scriptSig
and it puts them on top of
each other, just like this.
So that's the
scriptSig up there,
this is the
scriptPubKey down here.
And then it runs
this combined script
through the Bitcoin
Script Interpreter, which
is based on a stack model.
So it starts pushing
things onto the stack.
It starts at the
very top, and it
starts pushing these items onto
the stack and evaluating them.
And so the rules
are that constants
get pushed onto the stack--
and then operations-- and
these things right here are
operations--
OP_DUP, OP_HASH160,
OP_EQUALVERIFY,
and OP_CHECKSIG, these
are all Bitcoin opcodes.
Operations have different rules
as to how they're evaluated
and what they consume
off of the stack.
So the first thing
is a signature.
We're going to pop the signature
and push it onto the stack
because it is a
constant so this would
be the signature that Alice
might produce in order
to spend her output.
Then same thing with the pubkey,
because the pubkey is also
a constant.
Then we're going to
take this first--
now, OK, we're done with
constants for the moment,
and the next thing on
the stack is OP_DUP.
OP_DUP does basically
exactly what it sounds like.
It takes the thing
that's currently
on the top of the stack
and it duplicates it.
So the way that we consume
OP_DUP is we take this pubkey
and we create another
copy of the pubkey.
The next op is OP_HASH160.
It also does exactly
what it sounds like.
It takes what's on the top
of the stack, it hashes it,
and it pushes that hash
onto the top of the stack.
So after we run
OP_HASH160, this is
what our stack will look like.
Next thing is a constant.
So we take that constant,
which should be--
which is the hash of the pubkey.
So this is the address
that this money
is being sent to, essentially.
And we put that on
the top of the stack.
And then we run this operation
called OP_EQUALVERIFY.
Whenever an opcode
ends with VERIFY,
it means that it's a
little bit special.
It means that it has the
ability to, if it fails,
break out of the
entire script execution
and immediately cause
transaction validation to fail.
So OP_EQUALVERIFY
does what it sounds
like, it checks to
make sure that the two
things on the top of
the stack are equal.
And if they're not equal,
then it immediately
fails validation.
So you'll note that
what the two things
at the top of
the-- let's go back
to what the two things on the
top of the stack are right now.
So we pushed the sig,
we push a pubkey,
we duplicated that pubkey, and
these are from the scriptSig,
so this is from whoever is
redeeming the transaction.
So whoever's redeeming
the transaction
has put a copy of
this pub key on there,
and now that pubkey
is on the stack twice.
We hashed the
pubkey, and then we
pushed the hash
that was specified
in the previous transaction
that set up the rules for how
to spend this.
And then OP_EQUALVERIFY
makes sure
that these things are
actually the same.
And if they're not
the same, then it'll
fail that verify check and the
entire transaction validation
will abort, and it's
an invalid transaction.
So let's assume that
they're the same.
OK, great.
Then OP_EQUALVERIFY--
then we continue
transaction validation.
And now we're left with this,
OP_CHECKSIG, pubkey, sig.
And this does exactly what
you think it might do,
it pops two things
off the stack,
checks to make sure that the
signature is a valid signature
for this pub key.
And if it is, it pushes
true onto the stack.
And if there is a true on
top of the stack-- in fact,
I think if there's any
constant on top of the stack
when we've consumed all of
the parts of our scriptSig
and scriptPubKey,
then this returns true
and the transaction
is considered valid.
So this is a lot, and I know
this is kind of complicated.
So let's sort of step
through this one more time.
And there's just
a couple of things
that I want to make clear.
This part right here is set
up in the output of whatever
transaction we're spending.
So if Alice creates
this transaction
and she's spending
to Bob, then Alice
would put whose pubkey here?
AUDIENCE: Bob's.
NEHA NARULA: Hash of
a pubkey, actually.
Right, so Alice would put the
hash of Bob's pubkey here.
And when Bob's redeeming, what
would go in the input that
needs to redeem that output?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Sorry,
I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: Bob's signature.
NEHA NARULA: Bob's
signature and the pubkey
that corresponds
to that signature,
because all we have is a hash.
So those are the
things that would
get put on top of the stack.
So up there, we
have Bob's signature
and we have Bob's pubkey.
Again, those get
pushed onto the stack
because they're constants,
duplicated, hash the top,
copy over the hash, make
sure that they're equal,
and then check the signature.
And this is a Pay to
Pubkey Hash script.
It is the most common
script in Bitcoin.
And this is this basically the
standard way of spending money.
Are there questions about this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a significance
in having that
they're equal-verified
before the CHECKSIG?
Because it seems like
they're both verifying
tings, and I'm wondering--
NEHA NARULA: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So let's say that we didn't
have this EQUALVERIFY here then
what could a malicious
spender possibly do?
AUDIENCE: Well, I just
meant flipping the order.
We're still verifying both, but
if you did the CHECKSIG first
versus the EQUALVERIFY
first, does that matter?
NEHA NARULA: Oh,
that's a good question.
I don't think that would matter.
I'm not sure.
Would it matter?
TADGE DRYJA: You could.
It's faster to verify
the two hashes are equal.
The CHECKSIG operation
takes a lot of CPU time
so I guess the idea is,
if you're going to fail,
fail-- go the easy route.
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are all nodes
on the network running this?
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
Every single node on the network
is running the Bitcoin Script
Interpreter inside of it.
And the Bitcoin Script
Interpreter is known as--
what's called
consensus critical.
So if two nodes have slightly
different script interpreters
that would interpret
this in different ways,
the network would have
a consensus failure.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why not
just Pay to Pubkey?
NEHA NARULA: Pay to Pubkey
is a thing, actually.
And Pay to Pubkey Hash
is considered better.
And the reason for that is
kind of subtle, actually.
It's because-- so the
hash of the pubkey
is smaller than the pubkey.
And this is definitely
going on the blockchain.
We don't know if this is going
to go on the blockchain or not.
Not all outputs are consumed.
So let's put the
small stuff here
and the big stuff over here.
It's about saving space.
Also, the set of unspent
transaction outputs
is something that every
node has to maintain.
It's very important.
You are referring
to it quite a bit.
This is not something that
every node has to maintain.
And so you want to
make this smaller, even
at the expense of
making this bigger.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So then you
could accidentally
sign a transaction that has a
public key but a script that
doesn't actually verify it?
NEHA NARULA: Could
you accidentally
sign a transaction that has a
public key but a script that
doesn't verify?
Let me see if this
answers your question.
So here is an example of
an unspendable output.
The unspendable output
has an OP_RETURN
as the first instruction
of its scriptPubKey.
OP_RETURN does what
you might think
it does, which means
when you evaluate it,
it returns immediately
and says invalid.
And so if you have one of
these in your transaction
in your scriptPubKey,
there is no scriptSig
that could possibly
redeem the scriptPubKey.
You could create
anything you wanted,
and no matter what
you put on there,
it would never evaluate to true.
There's no way to actually
redeem the scriptPubKey
in this output.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: I think
it's the opposite.
I was asking if you could
accidentally get something that
would always evaluate to true.
NEHA NARULA: Ah, OK, well,
that's the next slide.
[CHUCKLING]
So yes, this is what's called
an anyone-can-spend output.
The simplest
anyone-can-spend output
is just an empty scriptPubKey.
Because a scriptSig sig OP_TRUE
in it would evaluate to true.
Notice here there's no public
keys, there's no signatures,
there's no hashes
of public keys.
The scriptPubKey
doesn't actually
specify any public keys.
And so-- but when you
evaluate this right here,
you'd push OP_TRUE
onto the stack,
and then you would finish,
and there would be a true--
OP_TRUE would push--
sorry, OP_TRUE
would push a true
onto the stack.
And then when you
finished, there
would be true on the stack,
meaning this is valid.
AUDIENCE: Also another way,
you could put the OP_TRUE
in the output script as well.
Then you wouldn't have
to push it because--
NEHA NARULA: Yeah.
So this is an
anyone-can-spend output,
and this is a
no-one-can-spend output.
And there's no
public keys in here.
There's no signatures in there.
So you can totally create
outputs that have nothing
to do with signatures, or maybe
you verify multiple signatures,
which we're not going
to go into right now,
but it's also possible.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can SIG have
a [INAUDIBLE] in it?
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yes, it can.
AUDIENCE: But the list of
[INAUDIBLE] are [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: There are
fewer than 200 opcodes.
The number of standard
opcodes is even smaller,
meaning that there's a
very small number that you
can use in your scriptSigs
and scriptPubKeys.
And it's definitely
possible, if you
write some weird scriptPubKey
or some weird scriptSig
to accidentally create outputs
that are never spendable,
or to accidentally
create outputs that
could be spent by someone else.
So there's a standard set
of scriptPubKeys to use.
And I would not recommend
going outside that set,
except for in the lab
that you're going to do,
because we have some
more fun ones in there.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you explain
a little bit more on the Pay
to Script Hash.
Kind of like what [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Sure,
Pay to Script Hash--
I don't actually have slides
on Pay to Script Hash,
so I'm not sure that we can
do a good job of explaining it
right now.
But the idea behind Pay
to Script Hash is that--
yeah, I don't have
the slides for it.
But the idea is that you're
going to put, instead
of this particular
scriptPubKey here,
you're going to have
a scriptPubKey that
includes a hash of a script.
And then the scriptSig has
to produce that script,
and it has to match that
hash, and the whole thing
has to verify is the rough
idea behind Pay to Script Hash.
And we can produce an example
of that for you tomorrow.
But the cool thing
about that is you
don't even know what you have
to do to redeem this output.
So someone has to produce a
script that has the same hash,
and when combined
with the scriptPubKey,
will evaluate to true.
AUDIENCE: And that script
would be pushed on the stack?
NEHA NARULA: Yeah, so the
scriptSig and the scriptPubKey
literally just get
concatenated together
and then evaluated as one thing.
So yeah, it would just go
through the same thing.
Any more questions?
So what do you guys think?
Is this good?
Is this bad?
AUDIENCE: Could you
try to [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So the question is,
could you DDoS a network
by creating transactions
that are not spendable?
AUDIENCE: So you
still [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: You can't really
DDoS the network, per se.
So this is an example
of a transaction
that's not spendable.
And see how it has this
OP_RETURN, and it says,
whatever.
There is this
pattern of people who
like to store things in
the Bitcoin blockchain,
because it's there, and
it's very highly replicated.
And so one type of transaction
that a lot of people make
is and OP_RETURN with a
hash of some data in it
or some data in it.
These are unspendable
outputs that
will live on the Bitcoin
blockchain forever,
and will be part of the
UTXO set, possibly forever.
Generally, Bitcoin
developers discourage
using Bitcoin in
this way because it
does bloat the UTXO set.
That said, there's nothing
to prevent you from doing it
if you want to pay the fees.
What?
TADGE DRYJA: It's actually
not part of the UTXO set
because it has the OP_RETURN.
NEHA NARULA: Oh, really?
I didn't know that.
OK, I didn't know that they
weren't kept in the UTXO set.
TADGE DRYJA: [INAUDIBLE]
they would just
made [INAUDIBLE] key hash
into whatever [INAUDIBLE]
and that would
bloat the UTXO set.
So it's like, well,
this is not [INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: OK, I
didn't know that those
weren't included in the UTXO.
So that's good.
So then it doesn't
boat the UTXO set,
it just goes in the blockchain.
And you paid the fee to put your
transaction in the blockchain.
So good for you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
architectural logic
for having a specific set of
opcodes that Bitcoin can run?
Why not use a more general
programming language?
Is it just to have control?
NEHA NARULA: That's
a great question.
So why have this weird
Op code thing, right?
I mean, what kind of
sense does this make?
So the problem with the
general programming language
is it's really easy to
shoot yourself in the foot.
It's really easy to write
a program that you think--
how many of you have had a
bug in your program ever?
Please, all of you
should probably
raise their hands, right?
[CHUCKLING]
And how many of you have
had bugs in your program
that showed up a lot later
than you thought they would,
when you thought your
program didn't have any bugs?
So these things, once
you put them out there,
these scriptPubKeys
and script tag,
once you put these transactions
out there, they're out there.
You cannot take them back--
well, not easily.
And they might execute
in ways that you didn't
anticipate them executing.
The more complicated the script
you write, the more likely
it is that there's some hole
in your script, some way
of satisfying it that
you didn't anticipate,
that could end up
stealing your money.
So with a general
programming language,
well, you might think,
oh, well, these OP codes
are super tricky and weird,
and I don't understand them,
at least with the general
programming language,
I'm more likely to write
correct things, right?
Eh.
[CHUCKLING]
Actually, having this
strange opcode language
has a lot of benefits.
So number one, it's
not Turing-complete.
You know exactly
how much CPU it is
going to take to run
these scripts because
of the nature of the
opcodes and the language.
There's no FOR loops in here.
You know you can't just run
a WHILE that takes forever.
This is a stack-based language.
And so it's very easy to tell
how long a transaction is
actually going to
take to execute.
And this is really
important, because every node
in the network has to
execute these things.
So you don't want a script
sneaking in there that's
going to take hours to execute.
It's also-- you can look
at the number of opcodes
in the script, and like I
said, get a rough sense of how
expensive it's going to be.
And that's why there are
limits on the number of opcodes
you can have in a script.
It's very difficult to do
that if you have a more
general programming language.
So those are a
couple of reasons.
And I mean, I think it's
important to point out
that Ethereum, which does have
a more general programming
language, there are
constantly problems popping up
where people are taking
advantage of transact
of contracts, even fairly
well-understood ones--
or we thought they
were well understood--
and figuring out how to
freeze people's funds
or steal people's funds.
So that's the motivation
behind this sort
of strange, stack-based
opcode language.
Are there any other questions?
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
unspendable transactions
outputs.
NEHA NARULA: Outputs, Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
comment on colored coins?
NEHA NARULA: Oh, colored coins--
no comment on colored coins.
I don't understand
them well enough
to talk about them right now.
Yeah.
What did you--
TADGE DRYJA: I would
say one other thing.
Most of the-- a lot of the
cool opcodes are disabled.
So it's very limited.
It seems like you--
there's a list of,
here's all these opcodes.
Oh, I can multiply
numbers together.
That's disabled.
[INAUDIBLE]
NEHA NARULA: Yeah.
And I do want to stress,
when you're dealing with real
money-- so not in the
lab for this class--
you want to stick with
very standard scripts.
You don't want to write
super-crazy, weird, tricky
scripts, or if you
do, you want to get
them vetted very carefully.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Who is disabling
and enabling these things?
NEHA NARULA: Great question.
So there are two levels
at which things can be
enabled or disabled in Bitcoin.
So first, there's
the validation rules,
so what makes a transaction
valid or not valid.
Meaning that if a transaction
is invalid and it's in a block,
that whole block is invalid.
If a transaction is invalid
and in a block, and that block
is in a blockchain, that
entire blockchain is invalid.
So there's that level.
And we're going to talk
about how those rules change
and who sets those rules.
But you can consider
them sort of, for now,
being set by the code,
the Bitcoin Core--
or the Bitcoin software,
which specifies what is valid
and what is invalid.
But there is another
level at which
you can adjust what
ends up getting accepted
or not accepted.
And that is what is transmitted
over the peer-to-peer network.
So there are transactions
that are valid, but are
what's known as non-standard.
And that transaction,
if it gets into a block,
that block is still valid.
But the nodes in the network,
if it sees that transaction,
won't relay them around.
So you'd have to be a
miner and actually decide,
I want this transaction in a
block, and mine that block.
And if you do that,
everyone will consider
it a valid block, OK, fine.
But no one will actually
send your transaction around.
And so if you're not
a miner yourself,
the odds of it getting into
the blockchain are very low.
And so those are the
two sets of rules.
The peer-to-peer rules are more
restrictive than the validation
rules.
OK, so we already
kind of started
talking about this
a little bit--
what are the benefits
of your UTXOs
and what are the
downsides of UTXOs?
So one of the benefits
of UTXOs is that--
do you guys see how they
help with replay attacks?
Sure, I can copy
this transaction
and put multiple out there,
but you're only allowed
to spend an output once.
And once you consume
that output, that's it.
So you can't really do
replay attacks in this model.
So it's a very
sort of elegant way
of getting rid of
the replay attack
problem without having to
store a nonce per account
in your system.
Another benefit is
that you can actually
get a little bit better
privacy with this UTXO system.
Because you don't have to
use the same public key
for all of your transactions.
You can generate new
ones every single time,
and then combine UTXOs from
different things into--
I mean, you're going to
have to combine them anyway,
even if they did spend
at the same public key.
So why not generate
fresh ones all the time?
And it becomes a
little bit harder
to track who you're spending
and who you're paying to.
In the account-based
model, you need to have--
it's more likely that
all of your funds
are going to be in one account
in order to make a spend.
Now a downside of UTXOs is
that they're complicated.
So when I first
heard about UTXOs
and I first understood how
Bitcoin worked, I was like,
why does Bitcoin work this way?
This makes zero sense.
An account-based model
would be so much easier.
And I mean, I think,
for wallet providers
and for people who are
writing user software,
it is easier to deal with an
account-based model than a UTXO
model.
Because people who are writing
Bitcoin wallet software
have to keep track
of all of your UTXOs
and then figure out
how to combine them
to get the amount that
you want to spend,
and make sure that they produce
what are called change outputs
the right way, so you
don't accidentally
lose some of your
money because you're
spending an output
that has 100 bitcoin
but you're only paying
someone one bitcoin.
You better make sure you have
that 99 bitcoin output in there
going back to you.
So it just makes everything a
little bit more complicated.
You can't just spend the
amount you want to spend.
You have to find these
outputs, and combine them
in the right way, and figure
all of this stuff out.
Another problem is
around fungibility.
So this is why I say that
bitcoin is not fungible,
because of these outputs,
and the fact that you have
to point back to the output
that you're going to spend,
which ends up creating what's
called a transaction graph.
So you can sort of see how
things are chained together,
and you can actually discern
quite a bit of information
about what's going
on in the network.
And in fact, the FBI has
used the transaction graph
in some of its cases
around Silk Road,
to see where Bitcoin was moving.
And there are many
companies out there--
Chain Analysis, Elliptic,
that provide services
based around the fact that
Bitcoin's transaction graph is
totally open, and so you can
see how coins are moving around.
So in addition to the
transaction graph problem,
you kind of lose this aspect
of fungibility in the sense
that, let's say, that I know
that, for whatever reason,
these coins came from,
let's say, I don't know,
a terrorist or
something like that.
You then know exactly where
those coins are going,
and you can kind of see
the chain of transactions
that come off of those coins.
And it sort of creates
a potential opportunity
for someone to blacklist coins.
Or you might decide that you
like coins that were produced--
that are fresher
than other coins.
So there's this ability to
distinguish between coins,
which is a little
bit troublesome,
because fungibility is
generally considered
a very good property
for money to have,
and this is not
entirely fungible.
But people are working on that.
Any other questions?
I alluded to this earlier,
but every single node
that's running the
Bitcoin software
keeps this data structure
called the UTXO set.
So these are all of the
outstanding, unspent
transaction outputs.
It's all of the coins
in the system, all
of the money in the system
that's available to be spent.
The way that this
is computed is,
when a Bitcoin node
comes online and starts
to download the blockchain,
they run through the blockchain
and continuously add
and remove things
from the UTXO set
to produce a UTXO
set that is valid for
whatever the last block is
that it's seen.
When a new block comes in, a
node runs through the block,
and again removes
and adds things
to the UTXO set as necessary.
Right now, there's about 60
million UTXOs in the UTXO set.
A lot of them,
unfortunately-- well, a lot,
in terms of bytes of the
UTXO set, a lot of them
are very small and are unlikely
to get spent very soon.
So that's kind of a bummer.
The UTXO set is about three
gigabytes right now, I think.
And so every node in
Bitcoin, in addition
to storing the blockchain,
stores this UTXO set,
and uses this data structure
to very quickly tell
if a transaction is a
double-spend or not.
Any questions
about the UTXO set?
Yes, SJ.
AUDIENCE: How do you avoid
having small transactions
accumulate over time?
NEHA NARULA: That's
a good question--
how do you avoid having
small transactions accumulate
over time?
I don't know the answer
to that question.
It's kind of a bummer.
It's not really in
people's interest
to generate those transactions
because you're creating--
I haven't talked about
how fees are computed yet.
But fees are measured
according to the resources
that a transaction
takes up in the system.
Fees are measured according to
the size of the transaction.
So if you have to combine a
whole bunch of tiny outputs
in order to get
a big enough sum,
you're going to have
to pay more in fees.
So it's not really
in your interest
to produce a lot of
these tiny things.
But there's not really a
good way of stopping it.
And in fact there have
been services in the past,
like Satoshi dice
and whatnot, that
have created a ton
of very tiny outputs
and it bloated the UTXO set.
I don't know, Tadge, if you
have any insight into how
to stop that from happening.
TADGE DRYJA: Make
the fees higher.
NEHA NARULA: Other
than the fees--
other than the fees, yeah.
TADGE DRYJA: Better
wallet software.
A lot of it's
[? unintentional. ?]
NEHA NARULA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that one
other [INAUDIBLE] is privacy,
and you need to
generate new pubkeys.
But would this prevent you,
in the account-based model,
prevent from getting an account?
NEHA NARULA: Yeah.
So I'm not sure in the
account-based model--
we'll find out more about this
when we get to the Ethereum
section of the class--
how you combine spending
from different accounts.
But Bitcoin makes it very
easy to combine spending
from different pubkeys.
In the account-based
model, I could
imagine it being a slightly
more complicated process.
But that's a good point.
Yes, you could definitely
create a lot of accounts
with a lot of small balance.
But if you want to
spend a lot, you're
going to have to
somehow accumulate
all of that spending.
Remember, I talked
about how there
is one special transaction
in every block, called
the coinbase transaction.
And this transaction
does not have
to follow all of the
rules specified before.
So this is kind of like
a hard-coded exception
into how Bitcoin
works, that there
can be this one
transaction in every block,
called the coinbase transaction.
It is the first transaction.
The coinbase transaction
has exactly one input.
And that input needs
to have certain feel.
This input does not point
to a previous output.
This input is essentially empty.
This is the transaction that
doles out the block reward.
So this is the
transaction that--
the block reward used
to be 50 bitcoins--
25 bitcoins, 50 bitcoins, now
it's 12.5 bitcoins per block.
This is the transaction that
doles out that 12.5 bitcoins
plus the fees of the block.
So it has exactly one input.
And that input has all zeros
for the previous transaction ID.
And then FFFFF for the index
into that previous transaction
ID.
I think the scriptSig can
basically be whatever you want.
It's not evaluated.
It might have to be valid.
I'm not sure.
And then its output
is in Satoshis.
So this is 12.5 Bitcoin.
Because remember, a Bitcoin
is 10 to the eighth Satoshis.
So this is 12.5
bitcoin, plus here
are the fees from that block.
And you probably,
if you're the one--
so the miner is the one who
creates this transaction.
And the miner who creates
this transaction probably
wants to give themselves the
Bitcoin and the block reward,
and so would specify,
in here, a scriptPubKey
that they could redeem.
Note that this also has the
nice property of making--
well, I don't if
it's a nice property,
but all the blocks that people
work on are actually different.
Because in each block,
the coinbase transaction
is going to be different
because each person is
trying to pay themselves
for-- the different miners.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's [INAUDIBLE]
them to 12.5 bitcoins?
NEHA NARULA: Ah, great question.
So what would happen
if a miner put,
like, 100 bitcoins in there?
Any idea?
So what's keeping
that at 12.5 bitcoins
is the same thing that's
keeping invalid transactions out
of the blockchain, which is
the consensus rules of Bitcoin.
It says in the code that,
at this point in time, given
the block height where
we are, that number
should be no larger
than 12.5 plus the fees
in the transaction.
And if a miner put a
different number in there--
they can put a lower
number, that's fine.
They'll end up burning some
Bitcoin, which is unfortunate.
But if they try to put
something higher in there,
the network will
regard it as invalid,
because the network is
running a set of rules.
And we are, in this
class, going to get
to what happens when you want to
change that set of rules, which
gets really tricky.
But right now, assume
that the network
is running the set of
rules, they're all checking,
they're all validating.
And so the answer
is, the network
would reject this block if there
was a higher number in there.
So this is kind of fun,
because you can sort of
put whatever you want in here.
And so miners like to put
advertisements in there.
And there actually was a
period, there was a time--
I don't know if you
can still do this--
where you could literally
buy this space from miners,
and put whatever
you wanted in there.
So you could put your name,
or ask someone to marry you,
or whatever you
might want to do,
to put in the Bitcoin
blockchain for all eternity.
But yeah, so miners like to put
fun things in the scriptSig.
And maybe we could show them
some of those things later.
Or you could go look yourself.